the idea came from originally Paul
terminal who was doing some sketches for
an UV art frameworks ravi fahadh ocearch
panel concept art a Yakuza busey know
Myeong soo sweet he had this comic book
style it that he really wanted to push
forward and he had this sort of very
emotional edge to his work that we
really all hooked into immediately and
we thought you know maybe we can
actually tackle this really difficult
story in a different way and really
bring it to people who don't really know
world war one in the same way i've never
seen anything about world war one one
day a farmer
an ex-soldier this era was
underrepresented and video games we
thought it was just a great great idea
and a great thing to try lovely Papa's
your toe shoes and see you will most of
our families grandparents were inside
this war a lot of people were concerned
with this world professor John Cena
knowledge monte la una y poco poco llevo
una cadena women photo sen ya voy a pass
attendant Rose kumaran saloon tell
Odysseus the somatic come on a bit fizzy
yeah yeah pwetty correo de casa nozomu
confront a and station return wanna
marry me it was really something that
there was strong and resonated with all
of us and I think that's where the story
itself sort of got transformed into what
is very enhance today my personal juju
is from Steve Mason spra the certain
personage in logistic companies hold on
this is from the the wrong generic
something we like them it is this
remodel hi Darcy said yum in my
additional ayla body disparity oil spill
the basilisk ed posted in today an atty
older here we're talking about the
horrors of war we're talking about the
emotions of war in particular love story
or we're talking about how different
cultures and different countries were
all affected by the war in different
ways and I think it's something it's
realistically the first game that'll
bring a tear to your eye and I think
that's something that's it's quite
special and very rare